so dmx man it impacted me heavily
have you met him yeah i brought him out
at a show in new york i did
and um this was
four or five years ago now yeah and um i
had flown my mom out for the show i i
don't think i got to holler at him until
after the concert
uh but my mom after the show told me
she was walking backstage and he was
walking backstage
and they they met in the hallway
and he like i don't know if he would
have recognized her as my mom
or if she necessarily would have
reckoned i'm sure she recognized him as
dmx but like
it he just broke down in tears and
hugged her and they had this
this like spiritual energy moment and
like
he like he he said something that night
and it's crazy because you said
something really similar on
on one of your podcast things to bill
berwin um
about you only succeed when you can help
others succeed
yeah dmx said almost the same thing that
night
and it stuck with me and he was like
you know my purpose is to inspire and if
i can do that then i was here for a good
reason
and you know his energy my mom is
is a big energy type person i mean she
describes this one time she got to
listen to the dalai lama speak
and she felt this like like astral
projection energy from him that you know
it may hit her and
and you literally like you have that
kind of spirit and i could already feel
it you know what i mean and like
and x had that like just this this this
power and this presence and this purity
and his energy and obviously he fought
his his demons and he had his battles
and he had
you know all his struggles and you know
but
he had this like this this presence of
positivity
and clarity that was just really like
professionals
did you know them too mike did you have
a good relationship with me no no no um
i met him i guess they were um they were
in phoenix one time and he was with this
uh he was just some little chicken i
knew our uncle
yeah and um it was in the same room when
they went to
any um i was on cocaine so the [ __ ] was
talking really um
he was talking studious so i thought
this [ __ ] yeah
this [ __ ] [ __ ] with me you know i'm
thinking he's [ __ ] that's not
my money this [ __ ] [ __ ] with me why
is he talking like that yeah
and he was very studious and articulate
he's very he was diagnosed and wise
i'm like cocaine that [ __ ] yeah
oh like i like the contrast in the story
nah but but but
literally bro and he is he was so
striking
for that reason of like you know like
he was he was so articulate and if you
never
met this guy you would think this guy
would be the most fantasy you would
think he's a beast a savage right
and then you start talking these things
are you [ __ ] with me man
yeah yeah no it was not an act and
that's really who he was bro
and like and i just remember just being
so same way kind of just like
surprised but pleasantly surprised
obviously because it was just like wow
this is a person
you would never think about talking like
this so
so loving and so positive he was just
like he kept saying thank you
you know thank you i love this like i'm
so happy to be here
man you know there's people out there
that love everybody but themselves
yeah they're out there millions of them